so this is my
this lecture will be probably the
least technical and actually it may be
even short let's see um
so um
so one thing i wanted to do first um i
in this lecture i will talk about
a couple of barriers i mean the
we already have talked quite a bit about
the stable fixed band fixed point
barrier uh for algorithms and in this
lecture then we'll talk about the low
degree
likelihood barrier and
list some connections and open questions
but before i get to low degree
algorithms um i just wanted to
sort of formalize this stable fixed
point barrier that we spoke about
yesterday a little bit more in
terms which are
more
complexity oriented
as meaning i want to talk about it in
terms of
detection instead of recovery so
so what is the
stable fixed point barrier so here's
so it's a very
it's quite a general
hardness assumption
so
instead of trying to define it you know
in its generality i'll try to
define it while i give an example
okay so it's a
it's a
you can say that it says that two
distributions on
[Music]
two distributions d null
and d d1 and d2 let's let me just call
it d1 and d2 on
on on constrained graphs on
constrained hyper graphs
constrained hyper graphs
are
indistinguishable
okay so what what are the two
distributions and how is this defined so
so the
um so the way i like to think about it
is in terms of
uh
um you know the
in terms of uh
these little
lego blocks
[Music]
for vertices and edges vertices and
hyperedges that you can put together so
so let me just show what i mean so
uh
so imagine you had the following two
kinds of blocks
okay your vertex
which looks like this
and it has d
the edges coming out of it and on each
edge
there are
there's an incoming message and an
outgoing message
they're half
you know let's say it's a the numbers
there are two messages on each edge
let's just say they're half and half for
now
okay this is one kind of a lego block
you have
the other kind of
lego block you have is
like a
you have a
half and half
coming in
and half and half going out
basically you have these little
uh
little
you you have these
um
yeah sorry you have these uh lego blocks
for vertices and hyper edges or edges
um
they have
terminals on them and on these terminals
you have incoming and outgoing messages
okay and these incoming and outgoing
messages are some numbers or some
distributions or one through k
okay and uh
you know
the the block itself
is calculating the messages
uh correctly as per the rules of bp
meaning the outgoing message on
u to v
is correctly equal to the correct
function
some you know some function of the
incoming messages
from all the other nodes
okay
so so you have block you know you you
have blocks like this right now there
are two ways to
sample uh
okay so firstly whenever you have a
you have blocks like this it gives you a
distribution of local distribution or
states of the system
for example
if i look at
this vertex
this vertex can be in the all zero state
or all one state or basically the vertex
can be zero or one right the vertex can
be zero or one
okay and depending on the messages you
can calculate the probability that it is
zero and probability that's one
okay and similarly if i look at the edge
like this it can be in state zero zero
zero one one zero one one right two
different four states and you can
calculate the probably local
probabilities of these four things
okay so all of this i can do just if you
give me the lego blocks for each block i
can
write down the probability for all the
local configurations just by the bp
rules and uh you know i have these lego
blocks there are two ways to build a
graph or a hyper graph out of this
okay one way is you take the
okay let me actually draw another
piece
like let me draw another piece here
which is
i'll actually use a different color
green yeah okay green is good so you
take green
so green is uh
is integral meaning the state of this
one this vertex is 0 and it sends 0 on
all the edges
and uh
so the state of this edge is you know i
don't know 0 1
right that's work so this edge is going
0 this edge is 1.
okay so that's the integral
so you have the
fractional lego blocks and the integral
lego box okay you can take the
fractional lego blocks and make up a
graph your only constraint is you you
know what is a graph well how do you
connect a graph well you take all your
uh
so these d1
d1
looks like this so you take a bunch of
vertices
and a bunch of edges
okay and
the you know this is how you sample a d
regular graph how do you sample a d
regular graph you sort of construct a
matching right so here you need to just
construct a matching so that you know
let's say the messages on this vertex
are two third and one third let's say
there is a two third and one third here
okay you can
you have to connect it to another node
for which the outgoing is one third and
two third
okay so if
if
this vertex v
says
it's in on this edge i send out two
third i get a one third and this hyper
edge
says on this edge i receive a two-third
i send out a one-third okay these two
can be matched
right
and similarly
so it's a configuration model
for generating a random graph
where
you have these lego blocks and you
connect up uh
edges where the incoming and outgoing
messages agree
okay that that's a model of graphs you
get a you get a model you get a random
graph that way
okay
another configuration model
is
the green configuration model where you
match up the actual values now
so
instead of so you have the green things
here zero zero
zero zero
zero zero oh sorry
please
you just have the actual values here
0
right and
0
1 right so so this this hyper edge wants
to connect a vertex which is labeled 0
and on one side and labeled one on the
other side and this vertex wants to just
connect to an edge which is labeled zero
on one side so they connect so
so that in the two two graphs are
generated this almost the same way the
only difference is one of them is
actually matching the fractional
messages on these uh dangling end points
and the other one is actually
matching the integral values
okay and the two are
indistinguishable uh
if the
uh
fixed point well
this is going to always give you a fixed
point just because you'll get a fixed
point here purely because you're
actually just matching messages when you
connect edges so you'll always be a fix
but no matter what value you write down
here
so
so
so
if your
infinite tree that you have
with these messages is stable then these
two distributions are indistinguishable
these these two distributions or
hypergraphs are in distribution that's
what the stable fixed point barrier is
and i guess to sort of uh
say why this is
why i had to state it this way
i like to think of it this way because
uh
this way generating a fixed point is
easy
the fact that uh you you start to fix
point is easy as as long as you match
the messages that are leaving so on this
edge i said it's two third one third as
long as i connect it to a one third two
third edge on the other side
it's going to be
a fixed point so
um
but but basically stable fixed bob boyer
says that these two distributions are
indistinguishable and so it's really a
decision problem hardness and
it's a very general decision problem
hardness where you can't dis decide
between two graphs and
the
its implications for recovery itself is
still
it's
quite subtle
um
meaning
um
let's take stochastic block model with
some parameters and you're trying to
recover the communities
um well maybe the
knife fixed point is not stable
so you get out of the knife fixed point
maybe there's a different fixed point
which is stable
and the question then is
that different fixed point which is not
the optimal answer but some other
different fixed point if it is stable
that could be a bottleneck for recovery
going beyond that point
in some sense because maybe you'll if
you if your algorithm does get stuck
there it has no this stable fixed point
barrier says you can't get out of that
barrier
so um so it's unclear how to use this to
talk about recovery
itself
because it's it's really a hardness of
distinguishing and
it's really saying that if you are given
a graph
at some particular fixed spot you don't
know how to get out of it
and it's subtle what will happen to
problems where there are multiple fixed
points maybe the naive one is not stable
but there may be other ones which are
stable and
are they really bottlenecks for recovery
or not we don't know
maybe your algorithm never reaches that
point so it never needs to get out of it
uh
it's very unclear what the situation is
so anyway so so recovery seems to be
very very unclear what the situation is
okay
okay so now we'll
talk about another barrier which is uh
comes about by thinking about low degree
polynomials as algorithms
so a general low degree polynomial we're
going to think of as an algorithm in
particular let's say
a proxy for a polytime algorithm would
be an order log n degree polynomial
of the input
well not all
log n degree polynomials can be computed
in polynomial time but really at least
they can be computed in quasi-polynomial
time so let's just
and we want to keep it looking at log n
degree polynomials precisely because we
want to capture many of the standard
algorithms
in particular if you look at log n
degree polynomials of the input as a
class of algorithms it captures
the following things
it captures
the power method
because typically what is power method
do you have a matrix a and you raise it
to the power log n
right or 8 a to the power t where t is
log n
and you look at the trace of a to the t
let's say
um and then this gives you uh
a good estimate of the largest
eigenvalue of the graph of the matrix so
the power method which is at the heart
of spectral algorithms is a log n degree
polynomial
and of course here i'm actually i say
it's a log n degree polynomial under the
assumption that p is order log n
there may be situations where you
actually need to raise the matrix to a
very high power
and it might be important to do that
okay and then
of course order one iterations of
bp or amp clearly fall under this class
and then you know of course local
algorithms
on sparse graph
and by the way i should say for anyone
who is going to watch this offline later
on
please stop watching this video at this
point
uh
you're much better off watching the many
different talks of alex wine which is
which are there online
of which this is just a derivative
so they're much better and they're
really there online so check it check
them out it's very nice and
comprehensive so uh
okay but okay so so those are our
algorithms so then we can talk about low
degree indistinguishability so we again
talk about
detection problem so detection problem
you have a
distinguishing problem you have a sample
from
pn or qn two different distributions
planted or null you want to distinguish
between the two and what would a low
degree algorithm do well as a candidate
low degree algorithm would do the
following
so it would you would have a polynomial
f
that takes
the input
and outputs a real number
okay and let's say the you know it's a
low degree polynomial
and what you'd hope is that
uh under the planted distribution the
value of the polynomial is large it want
that f of y
if y is from the planted distribution
this is large
and f y
if y is from the
null distribution
is typically small and then you have a
way to distinguish between
the two distributions
okay and so
so that you know that's uh that's yeah
that's the goal that's a reasonable
thing to try and
the
really i mean
nice thing about
low degree polynomials is that there's
such a nice
in almost
simple silly class of algorithms
that you would you can actually
take away the creativity and write down
what is the best algorithm in that class
easily
in particular
you know the best algorithm
in a sense
would be and given by the output of
optimization problem
so what is the optimization problem
well
so i have some func function f a low
degree polynomial f that i want to find
and what do i want it to be i want it to
be the case that
the
in the planted distribution the x the
function is large so its expected value
is large
and in the null distribution the value
is small
so
the expected value is small so in fact i
am sort of interested in the ratio it's
much larger much larger in the plantar
distribution as opposed to the null
distribution
so in particular what i want to do is i
want to maximize like the mean value in
the planted
by divided by the typical absolute
magnitude of in the null
typical magnitude in
okay
[Music]
and uh
so so this is a
this is a nice quantity and you know
like
if you find the best such
polynomial it tells you the best
algorithm in this class and
the advantage of d
is the
how good the best algorithm does here
okay so in particular if this advantage
d is order one
then you know that you know low degree
polynomials
succeed i'm sorry i want to say fail but
let's let me change this
is omega 1
if you find a function f such that its
value in the planet is much higher
typically then you say loading economics
succeed and distinguish between the two
cases and then if it's literally order
one if it's um
sort of same order of magnitude then you
have low degree polynomials fail right
so
so it so this class of
algorithms loading polynomials such a
nice
continuous
compact set of algorithms that
can actually
search for that you can define this
thing quantity of them
and
and in fact the way the way this
quantity is defined
it's actually possible to go one step
further
and make the entire optimization problem
almost
trivial
so here's what's going on
so this is what we want to maximize we
want to maximize this
ratio of these two expectations
okay so
let me rewrite this a little bit
more carefully so what do we want to do
we want to find a max or functions
with the degree of f at most d
of the numerator
i'm going to write the numerator
in also as an expectation over
the distribution q
okay so i'm going to write the numerator
as expectation
uh dq
by dp this is a likelihood ratio
times
f of y
well this is just the likelihood ratio
or the density
you could say this is the density of
q with respect to the measure p
sorry did i make a mistake here i think
i should say dp by dq
so y from q
that's the numerator
and the denominator is
square root of
expectation from y from q
of f of y whole squared
okay so
if i see so you know you have the same
uh
sort of expectation numerator and
denominator really how the way it looks
like
is you have a
inner product between a function l and f
where l suppose i define l of y to be
the likelihood ratio d p by d cube
of y
okay
this inner product under the measure q
of uh l in a product f
divided by the two norm of f
under also under the measure cube
so you know we we set up the definition
of this ratio in a nice way that
we're just doing euclidean geometry in
this uh
this space so everything is euclidean
your two dimension and you have a two
norm here
um you have a two norm
under that space and then you have a
usual inner product there so therefore
the i mean the function f that maximizes
this is really
just the
function that completely aligns
right just the projection of f
onto the space
spanned by
alternation of l onto the space span by
f
sorry
so it's a degree of f is d
so you are looking for the best degree d
polynomial
that that has a highest alignment with
the given function l
and the best polynomial that has a
highest alignment with this given
function l is just the low degree part
low degree projection of that function
so this is actually equal to the two
norm of l
the l less than d which is you take l as
a function as a
as a function and you project it onto
the span of low degree polynomials
this projection of l
on to span of
degree d polynomials
uh
nothing as yet
so far it's just uh
i haven't assumed anything about q
basically in any
under any measure you still have a span
of low degree polynomials and you're
just
projecting onto that span
and
now you know in fact if your queue is
nice like if q is uh
iid gaussian or if a q is an iid
distribution then it's quite easy to
write down
uh
the the projection of a vector operation
of a of any functional
just because it's just given by the
hermit coefficients or the low degree
fourier coefficients of that so for
example if q is
uniform on
plus minus 1 to the n
right so what is the two norm of
l less than d whole square this is the
quantity that we're looking at well it's
just
sum over
all subsets smaller than d
of the fourier coefficients of the
likelihood function
right so if
like this is i mean
um
you know it's usually it's often quite
easy to calculate these
quantities
so
so that's the kind of the advantage of
this
whole approach right now is that we can
actually calculate start calculating
these numbers for any for many choices
of p and q distributions p and q
okay and what is
what actually comes as a surprise
is really is that
even the simple class of algorithms
which is low degree functions
actually capture the complex seem to
capture the complexity of many of the
problems
so in fact for many detection problems
it seems to be the case that when low
degree polynomials fail all known
efficient algorithms fail
and this has happened
quite
in many cases
like we have the planted clique
the two community stochastic block model
or the tensor pca
and many of these things and what's kind
of very nice to see in all of these
cases is that you can just use this low
degree polynomials
class as a way to figure out what is the
threshold at which this problem should
become hard and it matches our
existing you know ideas about when this
problem should hurt this should be hard
so it's
quite nice in fact
in fact you know based on these
observations
hopkins
made this conjecture in his thesis
and just write down the conjecture it's
it's quite a powerful conjecture so
so you suppose you have a distribution
queue
null we have a null distribution queue
with iid entries
it's like a product distribution
your planted distribution is symmetric
so by symmetric
uh so
the way it stated uh
your plantar distribution
is probably if it's a distribution of
graphs then it should be symmetric or
what or permutations of vertices uh if
it's a distribution over
three uniform hypergraphs then it said
then it's again
symmetric or the permutation vertices
and so on
so
um so so that's the symmetry you need
and then let's assume that uh
you know something more than log n like
log n
to the one plus epsilon
degree polynomials
failed to distinguish
p and q
so then the conjecture is that
you know
then you know for a for any delta bigger
than zero
uh no polytime algorithm
distinguishes p and q distinguishes p
and a noisy version of q
sorry q q and q is already my so q and
noise version of p
okay this is a
conjecture the hopkins states
um this thesis
um
and
you know
it's a hardness assumption it's quite a
bit stronger than um
many other hardness assumptions in fact
uh
you know uh
the most surprising thing about this
like at first glance is that uh it's uh
2021 and i'm still stating this
conjecture it's not disproven and that's
probably the most fantastic thing about
it that you know such a strong
conjecture is actually still
true and so and it makes the right
priority predictions so that's the
really nice thing about it
um and so
recently um
um
holmgren and
alex wayne they
uh
they sort of stress tested this
conjecture a little bit so they showed
that you know symmetry is necessary
and
essentially because if you don't have
symmetry you can have things like error
correcting codes
uh with large dual distance so
locally the variables look independent
like the like the span like like a k
wise independent distribution locally
they look independent but globally
they're distinguishable
um
now alternately
you know if you have real value
entries in q
if you have real valued entries in q
then you have to be careful with the
noise model
that you the way you add noise to the
planted distribution so what you should
do is you should
make sure that you have some additive
noise
you don't have rd2 noise then you can
start encoding um
bits into the real numbers and then you
can make them distinguishable
so
um
so but
so but this is a conjecture but
that no polytime algorithm distinguishes
these two and it seems to be
true in all of the cases that we have
seen so far
and in fact probably the
the most surprising and strongest
evidence of it is uh in the case of
uh stochastic block models for
stochastic block models
uh hopkins and steuder they showed that
the prediction
of this low degree
uh
conjecture
um exactly match the kesta kestenstein
threshold
um so in particular it exactly matches
this stable fixed point barrier that we
spoke about
so that's nice and
so in fact so that's
that's
that's very surprising um
and
in fact um
i guess one open question which is
which i think it's been nice to have you
know
i don't know if it's really
maybe it's not that hard but i think
it'd be nice for us if somebody does it
is that
is to actually do it
prove that
the predictions
match for bayesian csps in particular do
it for the general class of basin csps
is just a technical
annoyance let's say even
fix some nice csp like not all equal sat
or something like that
and
not all equal three sat or some other
nice enough csp and show that
in that case
the point at which low degree
polynomials fail is exactly matches the
predictions of bp fixed point stability
yeah that'll be a nice
sort of thing to
confirm
between
this and so
between low degree and distinguish
between
uh yeah so yeah right i should i should
add that so um
so low degree distinguishability did
come out of uh pseudo calibration uh the
ideas stand out of pseudo calibration
which was a technique to prove lower
bounds for sos um and uh
i guess like you know
one of the i guess probably the the main
open question is lower bounds is to
prove that
low degree in distinguishability
implies iso is hard
this is i guess goes without saying this
like the main open question
um
so it's hard as in it's hard for sos
sdps to distribution at this this i
think this is the main open question of
uh uh sos lower bounds
in particular
it should technically imply all many of
the sos lower bound questions that i
asked earlier in this lecture
i should imply them so um
yeah
but but when um i mean there's a whole a
lot of literature on this um
maybe i'll get maybe i'll talk about
it a little bit later if we have time if
you have interest
okay so the next thing i want to talk
about is so we've been looking at low
degree polynomials as a
as an algorithm for distinguishing
but you could also think of them as a
algorithm for recovery
so
what is the recovery problem well you
have some joint distribution x and y and
what you want to do is
you know inference given y you want to
estimate x
okay on estimate x recurve
and
let's say let's just decide that we are
going to
compute a low degree polynomial and
output the value
okay just for you know let's just decide
that and once you decide that there's a
some sense the best thing you can do
the best thing you can do is
something that maximizes the correlation
with your original x
and that's an optimization problem so
you can write down that optimization
problem as i have written here
so
what are we doing here
we are trying to find the low degree
polynomial that maximizes the
correlation
with the original x
while normalizing of course the length
of the vector that we output
right so
given the length of the vector we want
to maximize the correlation the original
x
so in some sense this is the um
most obvious
natural thing to try
um
here
okay and
uh you could ask right like it is a
question that you could ask is okay so
this is a very natural
limit
to how well you can recover
right the best low degree polynomial
recovery is is a natural limit on how
well you can recover and uh
it's natural to wonder how it relates to
all of the other natural limits to how
well you can recover that you get out of
bp
in particular here's a question
which i know it should be nice to
investigate
is
okay let's call this the optimal low
degree recovery
you have the you have an optimal low
degree
low degree recovery function
okay
how does it relate to
all of the theory around bp fixed points
and everything
because remember yesterday we said um
the for example optimal base recovery
rate is
sort of characterized by things like
fixed points of bp
okay so
you know you expect that
if you try to find the best low degree
polynomial
that
you know that's the best polynomial for
let's say
two community spm
somehow when you try to do that solve
that optimization problem
the fourier coefficients of the function
and the function itself should scream
out bp right somewhere it should be
there
if we believe that both of these give
you the same optimal answer
and so this would be a nice question to
investigate like is there a
what is the
connection between bp fixed points
and uh
sort of the low degree recovery function
the optimal loading recovery function
which is the optimum of this
program that i wrote down here
and i guess the key
okay so this is now the key difficulty
with this program that we wrote here
is
that
unlike the earlier program
over here
we don't have
sorry i should use p here we only have
the planted distribution
in both the numerator and denominator
so in particular in the earlier
calculations that we did
for detection we had the null
distribution q and we moved all the
calculation to the null distribution and
the null distribution was nice because
we sort of dealt with cases where the
null distribution is uniform
distribution and our uniform
distribution
low degree polynomials it's easy to find
an orthonormal basis for low degree
polynomials that's fourier analysis so
hermitage analysis are all the things
that we have
but if you have
if you're doing the entire optimization
over planted distribution for example if
this is the distribution over graphs
produced by this stochastic block model
okay if it is really
that
then
uh there's no nice basis for low degree
polynomials in under the distribution
because
you know edges are no longer independent
this lot of dependencies between the
edges and therefore
although i can write this optimization
problem reasoning about the value of
this optimization problem or finding the
best possible f for here calculating it
seems much seems much harder than
uh
than earlier because of that reason
so that's the reason why you know even
this question that i stated at the end
is quite quite non-trivial because you
have to somehow get a handle
on the optimal low degree recovery
function
uh which is basically here to get a
handle on the projection of
the
optimal recovery function onto low
degree polynomials
okay but you know
even given that
there's still there are works quite
interesting works which uh deal with
this issue in particular uh this work by
you know sleel and alex
where they
you know
where
where they deal with this issue of
not having
a nice orthonormal basis for low-degree
polynomials head-on and they prove that
uh
you know in the for these two problems
uh planted submatrix and planted dense
subgraph for these problems there's a
detection recovery gap
where it's meaning there's a region
where detection is easy but uh
recovery is still hard
for low degree performance that is
okay
and
in some in
a quite a bit of an orthogonal direction
um
there are sequential works which use the
overlap gap property
to directly
bound the best load the performance of
the best low degree polynomial the idea
being low degree polynomials must be
stable and if you have overlap gap
properties stable algorithms are not
good so this this was a
i think boaz
bose outlined this argument and this
argument is very nice it's been used
right now for b-spin glass models
and for
independent sets in random graphs
um right now we have the best lower
bound against low degree polynomials
which is one plus epsilon log d
over d
um and more recently
like in
uh guy and
bryce one they have a
lower bound
for k sat for k sat
they
show that
there's a region
of the
density which matches the best known
algorithm
so far
beyond which no low degree polynomial
can recover
the
recovery assignment
and all this works
use overlap gap property as a way to
attack this issue of
how do you identify the best
low degree recovery function instead of
identifying the best low degree query
function you just
directly prove that no logical recovery
function works because of overlap cap
property
um
prasad can i can intervene a little bit
uh i said this yes um
i want to say that i think that
in the overlap the property that you're
mentioning
it has been properly applied for
non-planted models so like these words
that you're mentioning are for
non-classical so this is an
estimation right so the overlapping
estimation is quite a different beast
right right right yeah so yes so i guess
um
right so yeah so right the way i we
started out we were talking about
um
oh oh you're saying
uh
right right yes yes um right
yeah this is right yes because k set is
you know it's a case at you know for
example k set or large random graph
these are all non-planted uh yeah that's
right yeah yeah that's right
yeah
right there they yeah so that's an
important distinction
these are these are all um
there's no planted solution in these
problems
are in these lower bounds but the lower
bound is still showing that low degree
polynomials cannot solve the recovery or
cannot recover the
recover any good solution
yeah yeah i mean it's more about like
these are more about optimizing right
the noise
they cannot recover any solution with
good values yeah
yeah thanks
okay so finally i wanted to mention this
result more recent result on uh
statistical query algorithm so just to
refresh everyone so statistical query
algorithm is an uh is a model of
algorithms where your algorithm doesn't
get access to
the samples from your distribution but
only gets access to expectation of
functions
from your of uh samples of distribution
so your statistical query algorithm is
allowed to
send
a function fee
to an oracle
the oracle i think of it as
samples
uh takes m samples of the from the
distribution d
and
it returns the expectation
the empirical average
of the
v values on the samples
so in particular what you get back is
the expectation of fee
plus some sampling error and the
sampling error is just what you expect
to be you know if you had m samples from
a distribution you'd have this error
so that would be that that would be a
statistical query algorithm
where somehow it doesn't have access to
the samples but only expectation of
functions
under the distribution
empirical averages on m samples
and
the you measure run time
based on how many queries such a
algorithm must make
given the accuracy
m
so the accuracy parameter here here is
basically m because that determines how
good and
how good
an approximation to the true expectation
you get back from the oracle
and
for a given accuracy parameter ram you
can ask how many queries does
um
does your algorithm need okay so the
number of queries
made by sqa
is is the right it is its runtime
this is a proxy for runtime
okay
and
recently
brennan bressler hopkins lee and sram
they show that
for
you know for the problems like
distinguishing plant from null
uh statistical query algorithms are more
or less equivalent to low degree tests
and you know
beyond the most obvious but
the the most natural and canonical
bottlenecks between statistical query
and low degree tests
they are they are basically equivalent
and so that's quite nice because they
get statistically very lower bond set
right and
they get loaded with tests
um and so
i guess that's all i wanted to say about
uh
barriers and open questions um
if uh
yeah i guess i'm finishing early if
there are any questions i can answer
what's the tolerance
sorry what's the tolerance at which this
equivalence falls
oh what's the tolerance so i think what
they need is like
so so i think what they need is like
the um
uh
yeah i should
maybe not say anything if i'm not very
sure
i think they they need that the
uh
so
i mean
so the
sq
algorithm
tolerance being like one over square
root of m
corresponds roughly the concentration
you get for m samples for expressions
inequality and then that's like the m
sample
test like we get a correspondence
between that's the algorithm and a
literary
test which has access to n samples
so it's like it's supposed to like in
the statistical query other than the
the tolerance is supposed to be
approximately the number of samples that
you get which is which is a proxy for
the
signal to noise ratio so like basically
up to polar logarithmic factors we you
know we show equivalents
i was asking because for ising model for
instance you can do it with the login
sample
there's a sq algorithm of login symbols
well there is
i guess it's like i get we should
discuss it because there's a lot of
counters so
everyone has to check
any other questions
maybe i'll can i add a quick small
remark about the ogp for for uh maybe
this is related to what uas is asking
we're playing out so um maybe one one
general direction that seems to be
challenging is is ruling out low degree
polynomials for planted problems using
ogp
but there has been some really
interesting work on ogp and plenty
problems so i guess the main one i'm
aware of is uas and david gomarnik have
ice paper on planet league
it's a
lot of direction i think to think about
that
and there seems to be maybe one more
question in the chat i'm not sure though
yeah so
uh
[Music]
right do you have an okay so the
question was uh um
how are there ideas on extending stable
bp fixed points beyond constant degree
um
yeah so
that uh
so
so so the question comes down to so if
you look at 3xr
we've been talking about stable fixed
point barrier
and so on and
we can calculate the barrier for stable
fixed point barrier for 3xor what you
end up proving is that
what the barrier tells us that for any
constant degree 3x or sat
finding any
doing recovery beyond
trivial is
is computationally interactable so
basically the the
all of the theory that we spoke
yesterday it sort of uh throws up its
hand and says oh you know for no
constant degree it's easy so the so the
picture will just be it'll be hard for
all degree which is true and i guess but
the interesting thing is the 3x or does
become easy once the degree is more than
n to the three halves
and
i haven't
yeah it's a nice question to see if
there's a general theory what's a
general theory to make predictions on
those things
yeah
i think there is work by on kikuchi
hierarchy
which sort of
explains the end to the three-half
exponent i think but uh yeah
yeah
yeah i don't know if there's like a very
broad
general statistical physics predictions
maybe it's for the statistical physics
to tell us
this is the prediction of when these
problems should be easy or hard
such things
given the strong conjectural and
sometimes not beyond conjunctional
connection between sos and low degree
polynomials is there a way to
reformulate certificate problems
refutation problems in terms of low
degree polynomials by some kind of i
don't know relaxation of the
uh sos and so on is
for example in in going back to your
earlier question about alpha 2 and alpha
l for the largest independent set can i
rethink of this question in terms of low
degree planos
[Music]
yeah we
we know we actually we don't have a way
to do it yet um i mean the the even the
the current technology for proving sos
lower bounds
um like one of the promising approaches
is to
construct a planted distribution
and
sort of look at the problem of
distinguishing the planted from this
null distribution consider planted
distribution where the clique size is
one over rupee and and use the planted
distribution to show
to show the lower bound so in some sense
it's not intrinsic whenever if you
construct a planted distribution and
we are reformulating
refutations distinguishing problem and
uh
you know maybe for some planted
distribution you you can prove the lower
bound
for some planets you cannot prove the
lord in particular it's not clear
there's no canonical way to construct
change refutation
to become like distinguishing where we
have all the low degree
um loading likelihood ratio and
everything set up
right so basically there is no canonical
reduction from refutation to
distinguishing and the low degree
technology is always
well defined for distinguishing
all the low degree likelihood principle
and all the
local degree likelihood and everything
is good for distinguishing
for refutation itself directly there's
no canonical approach
but but you know one would hope that in
any problem for example independent set
in random regular graph
you know in principle one would hope
that okay maybe
the most naive planted distribution you
can construct
it actually gives you the answer uh but
uh
it can be tricky like i think for
example uh yeah i think for max cut
we don't have a planted distribution a
candidate planted distribution which
matches the refutation lower bond what
the refutation lower bond should be
the other questions does anyone else
want the mic
can i have something also from the zoom
or yeah
um
so i have a question about this simply
this equivalence here like between sql
limits and low degree tests like
i have been thinking for some time that
low degree tests are like naturally
robust i mean you maybe kind of implied
it also
before
but i i was never aware of the result
about sq algorithms being robust that
might be me missing some literature like
is there some fundamental reason we
expect sql units to be robust because
under this equivalence they seem to be
right or somehow
i don't know like basically i'm just
asking also
i don't know what like
algorithms are naturally robust in in in
one sense right because
if you're really taking m samples and or
giving away the averages if a few
samples are bad you still
i see so there is this advertising
you're right i see i say but somehow
somehow this equivalence
matches the robustness level is there
such motion also
like uh
between the two um
yeah i mean even i don't understand this
very well maybe some one in the audience
can tell me i mean there's another
notion of robustness which is more uh
is that
you perturb the entries of your x
right and low degree polynomials seem to
be robust for that
like perturbing small number of entries
like random noise on the entries
uh is there an intuition why statistical
query algorithms on a robust
question
statistical query one of the original
motivations for inventing it
as far as i remember reading this paper
was that it's robust to uh to certain
noise models
i think that was one of kern's
motivations actually wasn't to prove
lower bounds was but actually an
algorithmic
uh
framework for thinking about
constructing robust algorithms that are
robust to noise i see so given given
this like you know we're discussing in
this workshop about the power of
efficient algorithms but it seems to be
efficient for robust algorithms or is
this like a
kind of uh
uh
yeah yeah no if no
i should get predicated that all the
things that we talked about is in a
sense efficient robust algorithms in the
sense that once you allow for general
algorithms there's always the gaussian
elimination which is there which break
all the theories that we
think about algorithms yeah
and maybe uh if i can use like a few
more seconds of your time like on this
on the last equivalence
like i want to ask actually maybe the
people also notice that we're part
improving this like there is also like
some some exponential time right that
like the low degree method yes maybe the
optimal exponent sometime in the heart
regime would be
you know like
they they say that you cannot solve this
problem on time but maybe you know you
control this in that's an exponential
time
like is there uh i guess the sq model
also gives some prediction about
sub-exponential time like where they
able to prove this equivalent is also in
the hardware with respect to accurate
quantified statements that are not
precise exponential time-wise if this
question makes sense uh i i don't know
maybe
i can i can answer this i actually
wanted to say one more thing about the
previous sorry for
for spending so much time on this uh
thing but but okay so one more comment
about the noise robustness
so actually we have some requirements
about the distribution
which which also is necessary in order
to make the
problems uh equivalent because
the issue is that statistical queries
are not
bounded in run time so that makes them
not a good act like the the proxy of
number of queries for runtime isn't very
good for example in
uh planted clique like you can always
have a statistical query that just asks
is there a leak of size at least k in
the graph
and so
so somehow sq like it's not very good
for one simple problems it's really good
for
uh problems where the number of samples
measures your signal to noise ratio so
we have to do something to kind of tie
the hands of the statistical queries
algorithms behind their back and level
the playing field right so so somehow um
this also makes it difficult to to talk
about like uh
robustness because in some sense like
maybe models where you're used to
thinking about
you know the answer being robust you
know wouldn't fall into this uh
framework so that's one one thing to say
and then about the sub-exponential time
we we do get sub-exponential
um like we do get results in the
sub-exponential regime but
there um i think we're not exactly like
for example for tensor pca we don't get
exactly the correct
uh answer
so the the trade-off of uh runtime to
you know sample complexity isn't perfect
for tensor pca but but it does give
something i mean similar bounds for sq
thanks
oh well of course prasad is is normally
here once he's uh overcome the the
kovitz scare of from his
child um and so yeah for people who are
here of course you should go talk to
prasad throughout the semester and if
you're on the internet you can
i'll volunteer you person to answer
people's emails questions
um so thanks very much prasad for
wonderful four
lectures thank you